well under the term Equity Joe Biden has
made racial discrimination open racial
discrimination mandatory at all levels
of the federal government that's illegal
it's completely immoral most Americans
oppose it hate it but very few lawyers
have organized to stop it Bill Jacobson
is one who might actually do that he's
president of the of legal Insurrection
he's announcing tonight an initiative
called the equal protection project
devoted to fair treatment of all
Americans under the law without regard
to race the group of scouting principle
is there is no good racism it's
equalprotection.org and we are honored
to have Bill Jacobson join us tonight to
explain what it is Bill Jacobson thanks
so much for coming on lay this out first
if you would
sure Tucker thanks for having me on so
we're starting
equalprotect.org the equal protection
project because we're seeing very
troubling patterns in society our
highest ideal as a society is enshrined
in the Constitution the 14th amendment
in federal state and local law which is
you do not discriminate on the basis of
race or ethnicity and we're seeing that
unfortunately under the concept of
equity that there is outright
discrimination on the basis of race a
perfect example is in Providence Rhode
Island where I'm located right now the
Providence School District the largest
in Rhode Island is funded a program for
Teacher loan forgiveness new teacher
loan forgiveness funded by the Rhode
Island Foundation the largest charity in
Rhode Island there's one catch to it you
cannot apply unless you are non-white so
they have are openly discriminating
against new white teachers with this
program and nobody seems to Blink an eye
at it we have filed federal complaint
about it we're pursuing it but nobody is
challenging this the governor is no
place to be found the Attorney General
is no place to be found this is a
government program to discriminate and
unfortunately that's what has happened
to the equity agenda and we're getting
reports from around the country of these
sort of problems so we are organizing to
investigate these things to expose them
and if necessary to litigate them and
one of the things we're doing and you
can sign up at our website if you're a
lawyer who wants to help in this effort
at equalprotect.org a lawyer's Network
because this has to be a national effort
as you mentioned the uh the you know
Biden administrations behind it also so
that's what we're doing and we ask
people to come and visit and join us
yeah you can't just let him construct a
new Jim Crow and ignore it and thank you
for soliciting the help of other lawyers
this needs an organized framework and I
think you're providing it and we
appreciate it Bill Jacobson thank you
great thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight